Mới thoại, Mui Hai Nam vui về quen lập công ty làm giấm đốc,
sư lời như mấy các bột triệu đặt hơn ai mới tì đồng.
Các quan cạnh rất đều tra công an thị sát thái hoa,
nghe ăn vừa khuy tụ, mắt tạm giấm lựa trọng vũ,
sẵn đốc công ty chức những vũa tựa mại dịch phụ bông xem và mộ tạc vường quan tín,
thị sát thái hoa, vây tựa sự giúp tay lựa giả của các quan tự trước,
và tựa đạo chế bạc tài sát theo hồ dơ, phú tình lĩnh án Mui Hai Nam.
Với tựa đồng chế bạc tài sát, sau khi mạc tựa phú trở về quen nhá,
và lập công ty chức tệ hữu án thương mại dịch phụ bông xem và
lì bản vốn ưu tồ, xem máy, thằng sau nơi mấy ngàn công chạm hành bà
phú lạm hợp đồng phía chấp chức ưu tồ cho một công ty tại chính hình xấu chăm chữ đồng.
Và bên công ty giữ lại về chúng nhận đần ký xe ưu tồ,
sau cho phú xe bên nhận ký chấp, tháng hai nêm hành hành công chăm hai miter,
phú lạm xảy bà chăm chữ đồng.
Chào con ngàn tình gian, các quan tông ngàn thị sát thái hoa,
đăng tiếp tục mở giọc lưu trá phú có sống hiệu của tổn lưu đồng.
Vuy động vốn hơn hai mấy người với số tiền hai mấy tiền đồng như không trả lại tiền.